Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to "Brother Wake Up."
Now, this is a game where your brother has been put to sleep under a curse of some sort.
What is that?
Do I even want to know what that is?
What kind of Hello Neighbor-ass house is this?
I'm not 100% sure of it.
Let's see - Oh!
Thank you.
Alright. Well...
Okay.
Wait, he-hey!
Whooaa!
Hey!
Okay. Alright. I don't know what that was...!
...I don't think I want to know.
Okay! Alright! Well!!
I'm just...
gonna stay here!
Close my eyes
and kiss my ass goodbye.
Hello?
Who's there?
Who do you think you are?
Trying to give me a spook...
I don't even know what I'm looking for. I'm looking for something, but I'm not find -
Ooh! Hey!
I got a glimpse of a sweet ass!
Oh...
Ah!! Oh!!
Hey!!
WOW!!
WAOH!
They almost spotted me for -
AH!!
I... I'm fucked.
Hi. Hello. Hi.
Oh, okay. I guess that's how I scream then.
I don't know what I'm doing or why I'm doing it...
I don't know what I'm doing or why I'm doing it!
I have no idea.
I gotta find, like, 4 cogwheels I guess?
And what happens when I g- Oh!
Run!
HEY!
OKAY!
WELL...
I'M
Ooh!
Aeih!
Oaoah!
UM... (Markiplier.exe has stopped working)
UMBUH
Umbuh...
Ah! He's back!
What did I do?!?!
What do I do?! I don't know what to do!
*Whimpers*
I don't know what...
*Sobs* I don't know what I do!
I'm just screaming like a little bi-
AH!!
OH
fucking
GOD...
Dammit! I don't even have time to get my bearings in this goddamn game! Okay..
So what I need to do... is I need to be very very quiet
is I need to be very,
very quiet.
Probably hide my flashlight because that's probably what they're -
Oh!
Bwohohohoho!
Woah!
*Coughs*
Oh! Oh...
Okay. Alright.
There's a lot of these guys,
...and they want a lot of me!
Okay!
*Laughs uncomfortably*
Ah...
Okay.
Ooh!
Okay, so they can't see me unless the light's on.
So that's good, so long as I -
Whoa
That's him rumbling.
Oh, what's this? Okay!
I hear them around, but I don't think that they're going to be able to kill me.
Oh my god. Oh my god, II don't like the rumbling around it
What is all this
This is bullshit. This is bullshit, but that's what it is what am I even looking for?
I don't even know what it looks like I don't even know what it smells like
Hi, hi sorry. I'm sorry. It looked like I was that like crotch height
They're not my intention didn't mean to go face-first into your crotch
Not my intention, maybe I need to pay more close attention to to the crumble Wombles oh
Boy, okay. Oh well. I guess I can hide in that if we really want to do
Okay, okay
Okay, all right, what do we got here? What do we got?
What do we got would have got I think I think the trick is I just got to move quickly find
Whatever the hell and look why oh?
What's the purpose
Huh, what was the point of that
Okay, I guess we're just screaming at me, huh?
Is that what we're doing oh?
That looks interesting
Oh
Found uh found a cool glitch that I can exploit for speedruns. That's nice. All right
What do we have here sure over there's not a monster in here, but this seems to be something handy-dandy aah
Okay, all right. I like it
I like it still don't know what I'm doing, but I like it am I looking for the red pillows
I'm looking for anything
Good for a brain. There's nothing in here wait. What was even the point of coming in here. There's no way out
I can't even get through the oh
Why did I find a key
What's the key for what could keep possibly before
You don't even tell me I
Don't even know
What in the world?
I'm at a loss, and I'm nowhere near those guys
Not anymore anyway, holy shit
There's one
Okay oh
There's another there's another
Okay
Okay, here all right. Okay. Close close. Thank you. All right. I don't know what I'm looking for me
Okay don't know what I'm looking for yeah, but I'm not gonna find it
Yeah, all right
Okay oh
That's not helpful. Okay. If I could if you could just stop honking around
Yeah, so many big boxes no time boxes. Oh, oh
Okay totally fine
What's that wait hang on we got a box under we got a box under the boxes that's perfect
I love box ception here what nothing there's a whole lot of nothing
It's a coffin that I can put myself in somebody bury me. I'm ready to die. Okay, all right keep going
I guess what am I looking?
What am I looking for
Looking for I have no idea
Oh
Man I am at a complete loss I have no idea what I'm doing
I have no idea why I would be doing it in the first place
And I have a key that goes to what what does it go?
I saw something there's something glowing there
Oh
Dear oh
It's a gear it's a gear
It's a gear all right. Maybe I'm
Faster than these guys right I'm faster so if I just go for it oh
There's another one
No, yes, okay, if I just go for it
Okay, all right we're gonna be like that huh what if what if what if what if
That's caught on something is that caught on your Tootsie?
Little pussy problem oh
That seems to be an issue let me get out of here
All right, I don't know what I'm doing. I don't know how to do this. Oh shit. Well. I'm
Okay taking this nice and easy all right
All right, I don't know what to do
I'm at a loss. I can't exactly just run this out. How hidden would these things be Oh
Like the entire difficult, whoa never mind. I guess they're not that hidden
So there's a way to fight like I could find him, I guess I could actually try
Man, but the thing is like just doing this through sheer
Whoa oh that that's the locked door maybe I can at the very least at the very least I could get that key
and open the locked door right I
Could do that. I know how to do that. I think anyway. I think it was over here. Yeah, okay here comes that
Not sure why not sure why but if I can get the key then at the very least I?
Can try to open that door?
Man is it not here oh
It's not here is it
Shit, ah
The keys in a random place of course it is of course it would be
God damn it. Well. I have no idea where the key would be
No, thanks. I just took a piss that was very important to me. I'm glad I'm glad I did that
Why why why no
Oh fuck, all right. I can't do this
There's no way how in the flyff dicken world, would you do this?
Well Bing bong Bing bong. Go shove it up your dong dong
With it so anyway. That is
Wake up, brother
Yes bros not gonna wake up anytime soon
So thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to play this for yourself and try to beat it
I'll put a link to it in the description below. I believe the game is free so it's not too bad
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always
I will see you
In the next video
Bye, bye!!